[Music]
let's go to daniel in rockford what's up
danielle
not much how are you doing dr john we're
partying brother
good thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it absolutely man what's up
well i've got this uh thing i've dealt
with for as long as i can remember and
i've i've
been thinking about when uh in
preparation to make the call and i'm
trying to
describe it as clearly as possible but
basically whenever um
i need to speak up for myself or perhaps
correct someone
i usually have a severe anxiety and get
like a
fight or flight like or freeze response
and
i usually don't and i'll just kind of
exit the situation without speaking up
for myself or even for others and
it's led to some really disappointing
situations and just really silly things
like
that shouldn't
have to happen that i i don't know why i
can't do it so
give me an example of a situation
that you
um struggle with your response
um
like it ranges from very
basic interactions with people like
um like if i'm sometimes like i've it's
been as bad as if i've been at a
restaurant and i've ordered something
and they give me the wrong food
instead of like even speaking of saying
hey i didn't order this
or something like that i'll just like
eat it and pay for it and
not speak up
or like it's been like a family
situation where
i had uh
because i'm married married without
children but um
i've had someone in my family that did
something that offended my wife
and she asked me to deal with it and i
didn't know how to deal with it and so i
backed down which
um she's been gracious with me about but
it's not something i wanted to what did
she what did she ask you to do fight
some dude in a parking lot or
call somebody didn't say that was
offensive
no just address something that was
inappropriate that
someone
uh
i'm trying not to go into details but
basically uh
there was a oh i just said something
something one of my family members did
made her very uncomfortable uh okay and
i i should have addressed it
and i was
i was nervous because i it made me
uncomfortable as well yeah and i was
trying to figure out how to
address it and deal with it like and who
who
who told you that
how you feel doesn't matter
or is is is a burden
um
somebody's put that in your head or in
your body who gave you that
uh i
i i guess it has come from my parents
sometimes like
i know uh when i was younger
i had
sometimes i had
issues with like making decisions or i
would say like
uh
i would basically be discouraged from
liking something or like hey i like this
and like no you don't really like that
like you just think you do
and so i can hear you right now
daniel trying to defend them
and you're defending them because you
still think you're wrong
even though like hey i really want to
play
um
basketball basketball's stupid you
should play football any idiot plays
basketball only real men play football
and in your head your six-year-old
little head you think
no i want to play basketball but i
that guy's big or she's really smart i
guess i'm the crazy one
is that does that ring true
yeah and you find yourself out in a
football field with pads on doing
something you don't want to be doing and
now you're getting hit and hurt and
whatever it's because it's not something
you're interested
in and
were you responsible for the emotional
well-being of the adults in your in your
home
were there things you didn't say because
dad would get mad or mom would fly off
the handle
um
not quite
but looking back on it there was
i did see uh
how this is i did see that
um
i'll say like my mom had a strong
emotional response to like
she was like really over kind of
overprotective of my brother and i
and so like
this
like i don't know how to say it's right
but like if my
if my father had like
over corrected us in her opinion
she would like really defend us
or
or
sometimes it was just
i would see that there's a strong like
emotional like conflict between the two
of them and so
i would try to
smooth things out and also my mom is
kind of one of those kind of
uh buffering kind of personalities where
she likes to
make keep the peace with everyone and
try to
keep calm so i kind of inherited
inherited some of that as well you
didn't inherit as much as you
just absorbed it right it just because
the air you breathe your job is to make
sure everybody else is okay
and
somewhere along the way that became
you value the feelings of others more
than your own
and in fact that has
you you
see yourself in the world as a burden as
a bother
and
what's strange about that is or what's
unfortunate about that is is you know
what a restaurant really really wants
to get things right
and if they mess something up and
somebody tells them with with dignity
and and and integrity and and respect
hey man i
you guys brought me the chicken salad i
actually ordered the ribeye and um
oh my gosh let me make that right you're
actually helping them out because they
want you to leave really happy you see
what i'm saying and so it's actually
taking it from them
um same as your wife right um
a family member one of your family
members does something or says something
that crosses a line in her minds and she
says
i can't be a part of this i need you to
help
and
you're unable to help because well i i
that person's feelings are more
important than my feelings and now since
i'm married that person's feelings are
more important than me and my wife's
feeling right so
i want you to stop beating yourself up
over this first okay
okay this isn't a moral failure and it's
not a character it's not a character
failure
okay i want you to start thinking of
this as a skills challenge
okay
you don't
if you're bad at basketball it's not
because you're a bad person it's because
you haven't shot a lot of shots
and so moving forward
you know where this comes from you have
a peacekeeping mom who also fought all
your battles for you and you have an
overcorrecting debt you know where this
comes from
now the word i want you to keep in your
mind over and over and over is this word
called practice
that's it practice okay
i want you to identify that discomfort
when you have to have a um excuse me i
give you a 20 not a 10. i want you to
feel that real quick
and then practice practice saying
something
and here's what we're doing
we're just teaching our body because
your body has a
put a gps pin in
if you push back
it's a nuclear response and you need to
teach your body that that's an
inaccurate pin
that the place that it has pinned is no
longer there it's actually moved to
another place see what i'm saying
yeah that makes sense because
it's like it's a very visceral response
you know like yes but then but then that
visceral response turns into inaction
which turns into shame which then
heightens your body's
detection system for any other awkward
situation which then
you freeze again right and you you feel
this thing just spinning and it starts
being faster and faster and faster right
exactly and then your wife says will you
help me out with one of your disgusting
family members and you're like
you can't
to which your wife responds
frustratingly and then you feel shame
because you know you should say
something's that you're family and you
don't and then all of a sudden the next
situation you start you start getting
anxious about being anxious because
you're going to another family thing
right you know what i'm saying
yeah let's pull the string on all that
all that
i'm just gonna practice
and it might be as silly as
getting one or two buddies who know you
and love you and you say hey what i need
this can be ridiculous
but uncle so and so said this to my wife
and i got to say something and i've
never done this i'm going to practice
this
okay
it may be practice with your wife
and spoiler alert i do this with my wife
sometimes hey i'm about to have a hard
conversation at work or with a colleague
or something i'm saying about think i'm
thinking about saying these three things
four things and she'll say absolutely
not don't say that second thing you'll
sound like an idiot or you're trying to
fight or something and i'll be like oh
good
so let's just practice
practice okay
take the shame of i'm a failure and i'm
a loser and i'm always gonna be a wimp
take that off okay and practice this
here's another thing that's very
unpopular okay
um it's unpopular
by certain members of
different media ecosystems okay
but i want you to start exercising do
you exercise regularly
no i don't okay
whether that's going to a gym and
signing up for like a local ymca and
getting one of the personal trainers for
14 bucks a shot or going to a local
jujitsu gym
or getting a pair of running shoes and
just committing to doing a 5k or
something here's what we're looking for
global confidence in daniel
okay i'm not i don't want you to like
go
you're not going to go take krav maga so
you can fight everybody in your
neighborhood that's not what i'm saying
but what i am saying is you desperately
lack physical confidence
and i often tell young man especially
you work and train
and get in shape and lift weights
so that you never have to do anything
with it
that's why
you know what i mean
yeah
so that you walk a little bit taller and
you in somebody um one of your family
members
does and by the way if you're walking
down the street and somebody like
disrespects you bro
just walk to the other side right i'm
not talking about getting in street
fights act like an idiot but there is
hey
we will not be a part of this family get
together because uncle so-and-so
continues to disrespect my wife
and i've mentioned it to him continues
to do it
we are opting out we're going to this
beach so
you all have fun
it's developing that confidence and
unfortunately i have not seen anywhere
where confidence is gained by just
talking more and more and more and more
and more
i've only seen true confidence gained in
doing hard things step by step by step
by step and continuing to push that
boundary more and more it may be a yoga
practice for you but finding something
that's hard
with your body and leaning into that
okay so we've got two things one i want
you to set up scenarios where you have
to practice
okay
um excuse me i ordered a large oh excuse
me i whatever and i want you to begin to
move in your body if you will do that
for 60 days i want you to loop back on
me and tell me how things are going will
you do that
yes will you commit to those two things
i will
well do not under any circumstances walk
into a gym and try to beefcake it out
dude
don't do that
or i definitely won't be able to do that
anyways yeah don't i mean i have a buddy
he did that once he went to the gym and
was just tried like arnold
schwarzenegger and he didn't he couldn't
wipe properly for three weeks right
because he's just so sore
um get with somebody who knows what
they're doing or just knock on the door
of a local jiu jitsu gym and say hey i
want to learn
this this art and teach me this right
and we're going to go slow and you're
going to invest that money and that
investment is going to be in developing
confidence in daniel
and that confident i'm telling you right
now that confidence will ripple through
your work life through your marriage
through parenting through your families
through how you walk through your
community
man it'll be you'll you will end up
being such a radiant gift to those in
your life is that fair
yes i appreciate it thank you so much
you got it man all right you got 60 days
and by the way anybody listening to this
whether you're 75 or 65 or 35 or 15.
i wish there was a way we could talk
ourself into
um
confidence
but our bodies know
our bodies know and we end up just being
chihuahua was just barking
i cannot recommend enough having some
sort of practice on the daily where you
move your body especially lifting
weights especially engaging in some sort
of
physical
competition with other people especially
doing hard things
you will see confidence grow in every
other area of your life and not idiotic
confidence not oh yeah bro not that kind
of confidence but yes sir no certain
kind of confidence
strength and commitment kind of
confidence get good with a bow and arrow
get good with a
weed eater get good with things outside
and often those things can be used for
service too
and then just practice and feel your
body the whole way through when you're
practicing good for you my brother
daniel let this be the day that it all
changes let this be the day that it all
changes